-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Former New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie
announced yesterday that he is
ending his presidential campaign
less than a week
before the Iowa caucuses.
That means last place
is now up for grabs!
[ Laughter ]
The judge overseeing
his civil fraud trial today
allowed former President Trump
to speak for five minutes
after his legal team
finished
their closing arguments,
and now he's facing
11 more counts of fraud.
[ Laughter ]
Before he allowed
former President Trump
to address the court today,
Judge Arthur Engoron asked,
"Do you promise to just comment
on the facts and the law?"
Good luck.
That's like asking Jake,
"Do you promise you won't
talk about State Farm?"
[ Laughter ]
During a Fox News
town hall last night,
former President Trump
took credit
for overturning
Roe versus Wade.
'Cause, look, if he's got
to keep his kids,
so do you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter, cheering ]
[ Laughter, cheering stop ]
[ Laughter ]
In last night's town hall,
former President Trump
repeated his claim
that Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis
would be working
in a pizzeria
or a law firm
without his support.
And the fact that he thinks
those two jobs are similar
explains a lot
about his legal team.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] "I found this guy.
He was at a pizza place.
Now he's my lawyer."
[ Laughter ]
Trump also said he knows who
he wants to be his running mate,
but added,
"I can't tell you that."
Well, of course not.
You'd be putting
their life in danger.
[ Laughter ]
House speaker Mike Johnson said
during an interview yesterday
that he's planning on calling
former President Trump
to walk him through his spending
deal with Senate Democrats.
God, what are you
going to do next?
Walk a pigeon through algebra?
Guess which one's
going to take less time.
[ Laughter ]
An F train derailed yesterday
in Brooklyn,
causing several hours
of normal F train service.
[ Laughter ]
It was the same,
but with a reason.
[ Laughter ]
The technology company Augmental
unveiled a new device this week
called MouthPad,
which allows users to scroll
through their smartphones
by using their tongue.
Finally, a way to get
all the germs on my phone
directly into my body.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
the Coast Guard announced
that it recently seized
nearly 2,500 pounds of cocaine
in the Caribbean Sea.
The Coast Guard got suspicious
when they realized
all the fish [chuckles]
were flying fish.
And that was a monologue,
everybody!